die hinweise auf außerirdisches leben
werden immer erdrückender wir berichten
ja öfter darüber und eine neue studie
aus den usa zeigt jetzt dass der
exoplanet keppler 186 es wohl eine
stabile rotationsachse und damit auch
verlässliche jahreszeit naht und klar
ist ein stabiles klima begünstigt die
entstehung von leben enorm handelt es
sich bei kepler 186 f also noch um viel
mehr als nur einen erdähnlichen
exoplaneten und wie wahrscheinlich ist
dort außerirdisches leben wirklich klick
zum science fiction der kanal mit der
täglichen packung internet abonniert uns
nur dann verpasst sie auch nichts
herzlich willkommen vielen dank für
diesen spannenden themen vorschlag den
er mir über whatsapp geschickt hab zu
meiner persönlichen nummer für
themenvorschläge und die tägliche
nachricht über das aktuelle video von
mir persönlich findet ihr unten in der
video beschreibung bei der suche nach
außerirdischem leben konzentrieren sich
viele forschungsteams auf die entdeckung
so genannter erdähnliche exoplaneten
meistens kreisen sie in der
lebensfreundlichen also habitablen zone
genannten also in diesem bereich rund um
ihre mutter gestirn den stern und oft
handelt es sich zudem um felsplaneten
der größte etappensieg der astronomie
wäre sicherlich ein planet der genauso
groß wie die erde ist und viel wasser
besitzt zudem müsste er nicht zu weit
und nicht zu nah seinen heimatstern
umkreisen und so leben ermöglichen mehr
als 100 exoplaneten wurden bereits
entdeckt die ähnlich klein wie die erde
sind doch die meisten von ihnen haben
eben nicht diesen lebensfreundlichen
abstand zu ihrem heimatstern doch der
exoplaneten keppler 186 f passt exakt in
die gewünschte kategorie er ist 500
lichtjahre von uns entfernt und gehört
zu einem anderen planeten system keppler
186 f befindet sich in der bewohnbaren
zone seines sterns dem roten zwerg und
umkreist ihn einmal in 130 tagen der
exoplaneten ist etwa zehn prozent
kleiner als unser heimatplanet hat also
eine erdähnliche größe das kepler
weltraumteleskop hatte in 2014 eher spät
als er vor seinem heimatstern
vorbeigezogen war er gehört zu den rund
20 ängste planeten die wir kennen und
die sich in
barren zonen befinden doch die anderen
in dieser kategorie sind deutlich größer
als die erde und forschungsteams können
sich nicht sicher sein ob sie aus fels
oder gas bestehen und als würde
kepler 186 es nicht schon genug den
wunschträumen der astronomie teams
entsprechend verdichten sich die
hinweise dass sogar noch ähnlicher ist
als bisher angenommen
denn ein forschungsteam aus atlanta hat
jetzt herausgefunden dass die neigung
seiner rotationsachse sehr stabil ist
vergleichbar also mit der erdachse dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam die achse
neigung eines planeten bestimmt die dort
herrschenden jahreszeiten und das klima
da von ihr abhängig wie viel licht auf
die planetenoberfläche wo und wann auf
trifft auf dieser grundlage können wir
also davon ausgehen dass die
jahreszeiten auf keppler 186 es
gleichmäßig hintereinander ab folgen und
so insgesamt für ein stabiles klima auf
dem exoplaneten sorgen eine solche
stabilen neigung der rotationsachse sei
übrigens auch bei der supererde keppler
62 f zu beobachten die 1200 lichtjahre
von unserer erde entfernt ist wie
bestimmend die stabilität der achse ist
zeigt die geschichte des mars seine
achse schwankte wohl im laufe der zeit
zwischen 0 und 60 grad und so verlor der
1 feuchte mars seine atmosphäre und
wurde zur wüsten welt ob 386 f
tatsächlich also außerirdischen leben
ein zuhause bietet steht noch nicht
wirklich fest denn mit den heutigen
teleskopen können wir die atmosphäre vom
planeten nicht direkt beobachten
doch es gibt hoffnung und die nächste
generation der instrumente könnte dazu
tatsächlich in der lage sein wir bleiben
natürlich dran wenn er kein video dazu
verpassen wollt dann abonniert am besten
auch den englischen kanal einfach hier
draufklicken vom krieg zum science
fiction da gibt es auch die ein oder
andere video premiere glocke nicht
vergessen also dass hier und da runter
geht es weiter mit the first pictures
and stay tuned co2